[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Abdurrahman Waberi pourquoi Djibouti a
été la dernière colonie française en
Afrique à obtenir et à gagné son
indépendance c'était en
1977 au terme d'un d'un référendum
d'ailleurs
euh il y a la version on va dire
optimiste oui va dire que les les
dijibousiens qui s'appelaient à l'époque
ils s'appelaient même pas djibousiens
puisquon s'appelait les territoires
français des affares et des Isa oui euh
voulait continuer l'aventure au moins
pendant 17 ans avec avec la France ça
c'est scénario optimiste ou les
scénarios pessimistes dirait que après
euh l'affaire comorienne par exemple
ouais que Comor a été des années 75 74
75 avant euh les autorités coloniales de
l'époque on se sont arrangés pour ne pas
vraiment publier les vrais chiffres donc
on aurait un peu triché si on regarde
les deux comptes de votes on voit que
les les les les votes dans la brousse
comme on dit sont très bizarrement trop
à on va dire territoire français alors
qu'en ville il y a plus d'indépendant
les citadins étaient plus pour
l'indépendance que les donc on peut on
peut imaginerluance de de de gouverneur
de l'époque d'accord en tout les cas de
cause dibouti est resté 17 ans dans la
colonisation et c'est simplement devenu
indépendante en 77 alors qu'il y avait
un courant indépendantiste depuis très
longtemps 17 ans mais dibouti était
était français depuis pas mal de temps
mais il ou dans au 19e siècle mais il y
a eu deux tentatives de référendum enfin
deux référendum d'ailleurs où les
djiboutiens on dit non en 1958 et en
1967 c'était la côte des somalies qui
est devenue le territoire des aFAS et
des is territoire français français je
suis né français à l'époque il y avait
200000 habitants aujourd'hui il y en a 1
million à peu près 1 million à peu près
alors c'est un territoire qui est tout à
fait étonnant parce que c'est dans la
Corne de l'Afrique et qui est
particulier à plus d'un titre la
première c'est que c'est vraiment un
état un petit État charnière entre le
monde arabe et le monde africain tout à
fait c'est même une cité état quasiment
parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a qure nous
on appelle ça des des des cercles on
appelit ça des cercles maintenant des
régions il y a quatre régions quatre
grandes villes on va dire mais c'est
quasiment un état un état une cité état
qui s'appelle Djibouti qui s'appelle
République de Djibouti et vous vous
sentez plus proche de quelle culture la
culture arabe ou la culture africaine
non j'ai dans alors dibouti la
population elle est il y a trois il y a
on va appeler quatre groupes puisquil y
a quatre langue national par exemple il
y a quatre langues nationales le
français langue nationale à Djibouti il
y a l'arabe aussi qui est langue
nationale parce que depuis le 19e siècle
habite une communauté d'origine yéménite
qui est djibouienne aujourd'hui parce
que le Yémen est juste en face juste en
face qure qu 4 14000 1000 marins 1000
marins ouais et d'autre part la
population locale africaine et elle
elle-même en deux groupes elle est
groupe Somalie qui fait à peu près 60 %
les chiffres sont très compliqués comme
la Somalie qui est juste à côté c'est ça
et le groupe affar ouais euh qui est
quasiment très proche du groupe somaliie
sauf que on partage pas la même langue
on partage un certain nombre de traits
comme le
nomadisme l'islam l'habitat désertique
et cetera mais c'est quand même deux
groupes qui sont différents puisqu'ils
partagent plus la même langue alors vous
êtes un point tout à fait stratégique de
telle sorte qu'aujourd'hui enfin c'était
déjà le cas à votre indépendance quand
la France avait une base militaire c'est
la plus grande base militaire française
en Afrique mais à cette base militaire
française sont venus s'ajouter d'autres
bases militaires ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui ben il y a une base
militaire américaine il y a une base
militaire japonaise il y a une base
militaire chinoise il y a une base
militaire allemande mais on se demande
tout est grignoté par les bases
militaires c'est incroyable c'est c'est
exceptionnel ça au monde c'est oui c'est
un cas unique hein ah oui il y a
quelqu'un avait écrit la diplomatie des
petites nations voyez-vous donc en fait
Djibouti et j'ai déplore he c'est
spécialisé dans dans voyez il y a des
monocultures dans certains pays on fait
par exemple Côte d'Ivoire devrait être
une une une monoculture des cacaos et et
donc par des vers nous on va dire
Djibouti est devenu aussi une
monoculture des bases militaires donc à
la base française qu'on connaît qui est
historique qui est là depuis le 19e
siècle l'état jibouti actuel a aussi
profité des C certaines crise comme la
guerre contre euh le l'axe du mal dirait
buouche n'est-ce pas et à l'époque même
la France commençait à dire en baisse la
la baisse militaire on se
retire donc en fait la guerre du Golf a
déjà euh remis le le métier sur les sur
les fil si je dire donc la base
militaire américaine est devenue très
importante euh et donc maintenant on a
la nouvelle comment on appelle la Route
de la Soie donc là Chine qui voilà la
Chine qui qui exprime une volonté
hégémonique mondiale et donc la Chine a
aussi mis les paquets a fait une grosse
base donc on a au moins trois grandes
bases à Djibouti la française historique
l'américaine la chinoise sur ceux
viennent s'ajouter pour des histoires de
pirateries diraiton une base italienne
et japonaise et japonaise et là enfin
les pays du Golf ét pas loin donc Dubaï
et cetera tout le monde veut avoir son
morceau dans ces conditionsl est-ce que
Djibouti peut vraiment prétendre être
indépendant c'est une question qui qui
qui qui est très difficile à répondre
euh les autorités sont très dépendantes
de la manne financière qui vient des
bases ça c'est très sûr les dibousiens
que j'étais qui étaient né dans à
l'époque de la colonie française
connaissait à l'époque cette culture
donc les années 60 hein les années 70 je
suis né en dans les années 60 mais
j'étais adolescent dans les années 70
nous avions cette culture de de voir des
militaires des jeunes appelés du du du
du contingent avec lesquels on
fraterniser parce qu'on avait des
différences mais en même temps on est
donc aujourd'hui les djibouiens les les
enfants moi je vis pas là-bas mais ce
qui c'est et mes enfants ne connaissent
pas les militaires américains qui sont
les J qui sont fermés chez eux les les
chinois sont fermés chez eux chacun chez
soi vraiment voilà et ils viennent plus
bon après il y a des histoires de
sécurité mais il n'y a plus la culture
de de de que je connaissais moi dans du
mélange de cette oui cette base
militaire française qui faisait partie
du du décor elle n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui alors autre par
particularité mais pas tant que ça si on
compare avec d'autres pays africains
c'est que depuis 1960 77 date de
l'indépendance vous n'avez connu que
deux présidents ah oui mais ça c'est le
président Aptidon oui et le président gu
gu aujourd'hui qui n'est autre que le
neveu du précédentssument donc c'est une
histoire clanique familiale
Djibouti je vous apprends
rien tout le monde le sait pas non non
tout le monde ne sait pas tout le monde
ne sait pas par exemple combien la la ça
c'est le président gu Isma oui qui est
président depuis enfin qui était déjà
directeur des cabinet de son oncle donc
qui est aux affaires depuis
96 voyez ça fait un moment et euh
d'ailleurs la question de la suite se
pose euh comme beaucoup de cas et nous
avons bien sûr pas connu d'élection
libres et nous avons pas connu encore
des transitions en douce la question de
la transition se pose dans beaucoup de
pays en Afrique et comment concilier la
démocratie les attentudes du peuple et
la stabilité du gouvernement de l'État
lui-même de l'État nation ce sont des
choses sur lesquelles nous sommes pas
encore au point à Djibouti bien sûr et
dans d'autres pays africains également
alors aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une
situation qui est assez compliquée sur
le plan mondial avec une
guerre au cœur enfin en Europe de l'Est
entre l'invasion de la Russie en Ukraine
et il y a une opposition qui se
manifeste de plus en plus entre
l'Occident et ce qu'on appelle selon une
for formule qui
est nouvelle qui s'appelle le sud global
c'est-à-dire les pays qui refusent
finalement la domination occidentale et
on a l'impression que l'Afrique est un
peu l'otage de cette rivalité entre le
sud global mené par la Chine par la
Russie d'ailleurs aussi et puis
l'Occident c'est-à-dire les États-Unis
et l'Europe non ce que moi je est-ce que
vous le regrettez ça je sais qu'il y a
euh d'abord d'un point de vue
intellectuel je suis contre les
oppositions moi je suis plutôt quelqu'un
du lien ouais de laation pass du passage
et de la relation euh comme dirait
Édouard Glissant de la créolisation
finalement et euh mais j'ai reconnaît
qu'il y a évidemment des liens enfin des
des oppositions aussi binaires parfois
très fortes donc ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui euh le sud global avec et
contre une une espèce de d'Occident
fantasmé aussi qui est unifié à dessin
n'est pas tout à fait nouveau hein vous
vous rappelez la la conférence des
Bandou il y avait ça déjà aussi il y
avait la TRI continentale aussi donc
c'est une conférence qui a eu lieu en
adon 1954 ou ouais et euh
qui réunit les non alignés sous la
tutelle de nerou notamment et de
quelques autres en tout cas déjà on l'
présenté aussi comme un espèce de Sud
qui serait aligné qui serait ni aligné à
Moscou ni aligné à Washington et qui
aurait sa voix donc ça existait d'une
certaine manière aujourd'hui avec Wagner
on voit aussi que la Russie essae de
prendre des POS depis d'ailleurs en
République centrafricaine au Mali et
cetera donc ça fait partie du du de la
géopolitique ça c'est jamais m BL sont
jamais MV moi c'est Don je retiens c'est
pas tant à la limite l'opposition de
cette manière mais plutôt aussi qu'il y
ait une voix dans j'entendais par
exemple les présidents Kenan rutou qui
parlait d'une il parlait il appelle ça
la dédolarisation dire une espèce de
pourquoi on utiliserait entre Djibouti
et Nairobi qui est juste à côtéll le
dollar on pourrait pour certain échang
alors puisquon a des structures
régionales qui existent on pour c'est ce
débat là donc les États africains
cherche une forme de sortie d'autonomie
mais paraîêtre une une idée intéressante
sans qu'elle soit toujours à rêomberé
sur voyez la domination d'un autre donc
c'est pas la Chine qui m'intéresse c'est
pas une Afrique qui serait au service de
la Chine ni au service de la Russie ça
serait une Afrique qui s'estinenterait
par à la fois à la base à la base hein
qui gagnerait son indépendance en fait à
la base par des processus régionales
vous avez écrit un livre justement qui
s'appelle qui un très beau titre je
trouve rift route rail une des thèses
que vous défendez c'est une de vos
thèses centrale c'est que l'Afrique a
été dépossédée finalement d'elle-même
non quand on parle de l'Afrique on parle
de plusieurs choses évidemment mais mais
si disons le discours qu'on a sur
l'Afrique n'est pas un discours qui est
qui est africain d'une certaine manière
pour des raisons historiques par exemple
une grande partie des tous les discours
qui sont
d'unification vient de la Caraïbe
puisque c'est eux qui rêvaient pour
prendre en culture populaire le rég par
exemple le régé a imaginé voilà qui
vient de la Jama qui a imaginé avec à la
tête à
l'époque voilà cette idée d'une Afrique
réunie unifiée c'est un discours qui qui
a que l'Église ce qu'on appelait les
église éthiopienne caribéenne ont porté
voyez donc c'est le nouveau monde qui
avait besoin d'une Afrique unie donc ça
ce sont des discours qu'on tient sur
l'Afrique qui qui n'est pas forcément
euh des sens africaines de même tous les
discours par exemple à Djibouti j'ai
travaillé sur ce qu'on appelle la
bibliothèque coloniale quand je voulais
devenir écrivain et que j'ai parlé de
Djibouti le seul lieu où j'ai trouvé le
nom de Djibouti c'est chez mon frère che
chez Kessel chez é français c'est ça
c'est ce qu'on appelle la littérature
coloniale mais parce que c'est là d'
monfred a écrit sur Djibouti avant que
j'arrive à écrire sur Djibouti donc vous
voyez que là je trouve Djibouti dans la
bibliothèque qui serait la moins
n'est-ce pas indiquée au départ oui donc
c'est c'est ces contradictions là qui
m'intéressent et le discours concien t
sur l'Afrique dirait les philosophes m
il appelle ça à la bibliothèque
coloniale ce sont des discours qui ont
été par
l'anthropologie par l'histoire coloniale
par la médecine coloniale et cetera par
les libérations américaines au sens
caribéenne les églises caribéennes ont
inventé une forme d'Afrique donc en fait
ces discours là ne disent pas
grand-chose ou disent si peu de choses
sur Les Afriques réelles et justement
Les Afriques c'est intéressant vous vous
utilisiez ce ce pluriel parce que vous
avez écrit avec Alam bancou un
dictionnaire en joué des cultures
africaines qu'est-ce que vous vouliez
montrer par là vous vouliez réhabilité
des cultures qui étaient perdues on vous
voit là tous les deux bah nous sommes à
la fois des artistes et des enseignants
voyez on a on a on on voulez faire un
dictionnaire qui soit d'abord sur le
modèles de de d'autres dictionnaires que
vous connaissez chez plan le
dictionnaire du vin dinaire amoureux ça
du vin du et cetera donc avec alin on a
imaginé une manière d'ouvrir c'est en
fait comme si on ouvrait notre malâ et
mal à histoire he on sortait des
articles en disant bah tenz par exemple
si je vous parle de Rambo est un
africain pour moi Arthur Rambo he à
Djibouti aussi évidemment qui voulait
même mourir à Djibouti donc il y a pas
plus africains pour moi plus attachant
que Arthur Hambo et et donc c'est une
manière à la fois de vulgariser la
bibliothèque commune entre Français
africain et aussi de faire œuvre
d'éducation al ce qui est intéressant
vous avez parlé de Kessel de montfred
qui qui était qui sont passés à Djibouti
des grands voyageurs euh est-ce que
l'histoire qu'ils ont raconté les
histoires qu'ils ont raconté vous les
vouslez réapproprier ou vous estimez
qu'il faut revisiter tout ça et est-ce
que vous participez par exemple à ce
mouvement aujourd'hui qui très important
aux États-Unis vous devez le croiser là
où vous enseignez à Washington
c'est-à-dire le wisme où on remet en
question certaines vérités historiques
non non parce que le wisme est est est
déboulonné les statuts c'est un débat de
type on va
dire politicosal qui qui qui qui qui
peut parfois se justifier ce que nous
voulons faire c'est c'est réisiter les
les bibliothèques ce qui m'intéresse
queelle c'est qu'il a pu écrire des
choses sur les miens et donc les livres
sont là ils sont à moi pourquoi je vais
même les wiser je vais les lire et
m'approprier pour monfè c'est pareil
pour l'ti c'est pareil donc moi j'ai
trafique avec cette littérature là c'est
pas des gens avec qui je suis en
opposition ça serait même des grands
oncles il sont pas là ouais que je
chéris parfois que j'engueule mais ils
sont partis de mon imaginaire à moi et
de mon histoire à moi vous avez lu le le
roman d'p de ltil j'imagine que le
vocabulaire a dû vous gêner non c'est
c'est d'époque mais c'est voilà c'est ça
vous comprenez ça non mais évidemment
qu'il disent qu'il disent noir ou Nère
c'est pas écrit d'aujourd'hui il est
même pas là donc de cult moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est c'est ce que j'en fais
je vais pas les faire disparaître moi je
vais le remettre en circulation et
l'utiliser à ma manière en enlvant deux
trois mots qui m'intéressent pas c'est
ça l'histoire moi qui suis un jeune
enfin un jeune je suis plus jeune
d'ailleurs mais quand j'étais écriva on
me disait jeun écriv pourquoi je vais
revendiquer une partie de l'histoire et
ni une autre tu vois
ouais
donc je suis pas dans le dans le
déboulonnage je suis dans la relation
tout vous êtes dans la relation vous
êtes très attaché à la Francophonie
aussi d'ailleurs moi en fait je voudrais
une francophonie de tous les jours pas
la francophonie d'exception où on se
retrouve la 3è semaine du mois de de
mars pour fêter la francophonie la
francophonie elle appartient à tous les
usagers de la langue française et on
voudrait la on voudrait la la fêter la
célébrer tous les jours ici dis que la
francophonie c'est un instrument de
néocolonialisme et qu'elle vient dans
les bagages du colonialisme c'est
évident oui mais aujourd'hui personne
euh ne ne demande d'écrire d'une telle
manière ou telle manière c'estàut dire
quand vous avez des écrivains qui sont à
Abidjan qui la créolisent par exemple
Abidjan il y a les noti il y a un argot
noi si vous écoutez la chanson qu'
ivoirienne des coup décalé c'est du
français mais c'est du français qui a
déjà évolué personne n'est allé euh
légiférer là-dessus donc ça appartient
aux Ivoiriens donc je vois même pas le
problème qu'elle était historiquement
coloniale que la France puisse utiliser
la langue française comme comme comme
outil diplomatique c'est entendu ou mais
que la langue française est devenue
africaine depuis des siècles aussi en
depuis au moins des décennies pas des
siècles mais depuis au moins un
demi-siècle c'est entendu aussi donc les
choses ne sont pas contradictoires elles
sont complexes vous avez écrit euh au
président Macron je crois pour lui dire
mais quel projet de la Francophonie vous
voulez faire j'ai pas l'impression que
vous sachiez précisément ce que vous
voulez euh vous pourquoi qu'est-ce qui
vous a gêné j' avait écrit alors là il
faut réplacer les débat c'était à
l'époque avant qu'il fasse les les
discours à la l'Académie française fait
un discours sur la francophonie et la
langue partagée ou je sais plus donc
j'avais regardé sur le sites du de la PR
de l'Élysée et j'avais trouvé deux deux
deux occurrences que j'avais commenté
donc ce que je lui reprochais c'était
une francophonie qui ser qui était un
peu gfam un peu électronique et cetera
et moi j'ai dit j'étais attaché à l'an
la francophonie de la startup nation qui
c'est ça et vous vous rappelez qu'il y
avait plus dans les premiers
gouvernement de Monsieur Macron il y
avait plus un secrétariat d'État ou un
ministre délégué à la Francophonie avec
un vrai budget et cetera donc j'ai j'ai
déploré à la fois la disparition de la
Francophonie comme secrétariat d'État et
moi qui suis attaché euh alors que nos
instituts français sont dans un état
souvent
lamentable je voulais voilà renforcer la
francophonie en France puisque je suis
aussi français d'une part et d'autre
part qu'on que que la francophonie soit
soit pas l'exception mais la règle de
tous les jours par exemple que dans nos
ambassades aux instances européennes on
utilise aussi du français donc que Paris
soit pas le mauvais exemple les mauvais
élèves et disent au francophones par
exemple une fois la une fois l'an soyons
francophonees la langue française pour
vous c'est une langue d'émancipation
c'est une langue de libération le deux
en fait dire que on peut avoir une le
gouvernement français peut utiliser la
langue comme comme outil diplomatique
c'est entendu mais la langue français a
été utilisé et et et vécu et a été euh
accaparé j'allais dire par exemple par
les premiers indépendantistes des pays
colonisés voyez donc quand un quand vous
avez quand quelqu'un a été colonisé vous
lui avez donné un
bagage dans sa nen vous avez mis quelque
chose lui ou elle peut utiliser ça par
exemple les indépendantistes africains
algériens voire vietnamiens avaient
utilisé la langue française comme outil
d'émancipation et dans ce cas-là il
s'est raccordé à l'histoire je sais pas
de la Révolution française ou de la
commune ou de ce qu'on veut voyez ou fr
populaire donc on peut très bienutiliser
et moi je suis fils de cette manière là
par exemple d'un Hugo ouais euh du on a
parlé de Rambo d'un Rambo proche de
communard par exemple donc ça c'est
l'héritage qui me plaît il peut y avoir
des héritages ou une part de l'héritage
qui me plaiseent moins mais j'ai j'ai
j'ai fais silence j'ai fait silence ou G
voyez quand vous êtes dans une famille
vous avez vous avez des oncles vertueux
et des oncles moins vertueux donc le
l'oncle Albert qui est moins vertueux
bah on le cache et l'on plus vertueux on
on le on s'attache à celui-là voyez fait
nous-même nous-même on fait ça dans
notre famille alors justement sur le
continent africain quel est l'homme ou
la femme politique qui pour vous
symbolise et bien justement l'Afrique il
y en a des des périodes je serai
d'accord avec Suleiman Bachir par
exemple
pour parfois rédimer l'image des sangor
par exemple on a on a très facilement un
peu cassé sangor alors
sangor vous vous défendez sangor vous en
tout cas pour son œuvre culturelle et
pour avoir installé l'État sénégalais
oui il a on n'est pas tous d'accord avec
tout ce qu'il a fait mais la la le fait
d'avoir installé l'état de lui avoir
donné une assise est tout à fait
honorable d'autres son action pour la
francophonie aussi moi j'étais étudiant
en Normandie je l' rencontré donc
c'était un homme avec qui on on
discutait je lui avais écrit une très
belle lettre ceci ou C et donc c'est un
homme de culture et oui sur sa
francophonie aussi ça me dérange pas on
a trop facile décrier parce que c'était
facile cette époque aussi voyez
normalement les générations elles se
forment à à comment dire en opposition
chercher des noises aux anciens donc
elle a formé une des générations
d'Africains d'artistes africains se sont
formés aussi à casser du sucre s s très
bien à l'opposé ça me plairait de citer
Sankara qui navit Thomas Sara qui
n'était aux affaires que pendant 4 ans
et qui vient président du Burkina Faso
Burkina Faso qui a créé les Burkina ENF
l'état d'avant s'appelait la Volta Volta
le pays des hommes intègres donc en 4
ans il a aussi donné une autre manière
de de de faire pays de faire nation et
c'est très différent des sangor voyez et
moi je suis pas des oppositions j'essaie
de trouver un intérêt et in utilité et
finalement usage aujourd'hui historique
chez l'un et chez l'autre je prends des
choses chez l'un et chez l'autre vous
êtes un écrivain donc d'origine
djiboutienne vous écrivez beaucoup sur
la condition sociale sur l'histoire sur
la colonisation est-ce qu'on est
nécessaire un écrivain engagé est-ce que
vous estimez que vous êtes un un
écrivain engagé vous avez écrit par
exemple une fresque en trois volumes sur
sur votre pays sur Djibouti le premier
volume ça s'appelait le le le pays sans
ombre en 1994 après il y a eu cahier
nomade vous parliz des nomades tout à
l'heure et les affares c'est aussi
beaucoup ça en 1996 et puis
Balbala 2 ans plus tard donc tout ça ça
forme une fresque est-ce que vous
estimez que vous êtes un écrivain engagé
vous connaissez la réponse je préfère
être un écrivain engageant qu'un
écrivain engagé mais engagé engagé
signifierait un écrivain qui ou une
écrivaine d'ailleurs qui prête attention
à son entour donc ça me dérange pas ça
signifie pas qu'on
est qu'on vulgarise un dogme ou qu'on
essaie de transmettre un message
univoque et cetera donc c'est pour moi
un écrivain engagé et engageant surtout
avec une avec des thématiques une langue
engageante ça signifie un équivalent qui
n'est pas indifférent à son à son
environnement ouais donc oui
si ça signifie un écrivain qui
s'intéresse à son temps qui est de son
temps et qui est de son époque c'est
pour ça que vous êtes allé au Rwanda et
vous avez écrit un beau livre d'ailleurs
un très beau livre qui s'appelle moisson
de crâne alors ces projets
s'inscrivaient à l'époque on appelait ça
d'ailleurs l'inventaire Jospin qui était
là donc avec beaucoup d'autres écrivains
africains de l'époque nous nous sommes
rendus à Kigali partager un temps de
silence et de deuil avec les Rwandais
vous avez cette fabuleuse phrase dans ce
livre le malheur danse et sotilles au
bras de l'histoire c'est incroyable
cette phrase là ouais c'est je sais pas
si c'est bah si c'est quand même alors
en 2008 il y a quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bien qui s'appelle Jean-Marie
leclésio oui qui obtient le Prix Nobel
ou de littérature euh qui lui-même
connaît bien l'Afrique pour y avoir
beaucoup voyagé et pour avoir écrit sur
l'Afrique aussi l'Africain un roman
magnifique il a l'Africain roman
magnifique et son prix Nobel il vous le
dédie et pourquoi bah d'abord vous êtes
très fier de ça ah ben je suis très fier
et j'ai quand j'ai j'ai maintenant c'est
c'est je l' entendu je l'ai je l'ai lu
mais la première fois j'avais j'avais lu
cet hommage là j'ai fait tris trois saut
prier en arrière n'est- pas non mais
évidemment donc Jean-Marie l'clésux est
d'amord un homme généreux et d'ailleurs
il cite beaucoup de gens dans son
hommage à dans son prix le le le le
discours du prix Nobel où il me cite il
cite d'autres il ne cite pas je suis pas
le seul à être cité mais donc c'est un
homme généreux c'est un homme qui fait
aussi comme je disais tout à l'heure qui
fait famille il cite des écrivains avec
lesquels il partagent la langue
française par exemple ce qu'on appelle
les écrivains francophones il cite par
exemple des écrivains qu'on appelle
indigène ou autochtone parce qu'il a les
soucis des fleuves des
rivières donc ce qu'on appellera
maintenant l'écosystème il est très
imprégné euh donc il cite plein de gens
qu'il aiment et et de ces points de vue
là c'est un un grand frère on va dire
vous le connaissez bien oui oui
personnellement je les connais très bien
oui et vous le connaissiez avant
qu'ili comme oui oui bien sûr on se
rencontrit dans des salon et comme
j'étais
lecteur c'est un homme qui voyage et qui
fait voyager la France Maurice les lieux
où il a habité ensemble il il habitait
dans le au sud des États-Unis chez les
Indiens on va presque dire dans le
nouveau- Mexique donc c'est un homme qui
balade de monde et qui fait rencontrer
des monde mais je en profite pour dire
que après Jean-Marie Gustave l'eclésio
gaveclésio nous avons eu encore Patrick
Modiano et Annie hernaud en 15 ans nous
de la langue française avons eu trois
prix Nobel oui ce qui est exceptionnel
euh quel est votre écrivain africain
préféré ah il y en a des il y en a des
toutes j'allais dire c'est comme les ça
dépend des âges euh donc j'ai beaucoup
aimé euh pourquoi j'ai dit parce que on
aurait l'impression j'aime plus n'est-ce
pas mais j'ai fréquenter des écrivains
euh des gens comme katbiasine en Algérie
euh comme chinobe qui a fait une langue
très grand écrivain donc voyez j'aime
beaucoup là encore si il est mort aussi
mais moi un des plus grands écrivains
que j'aimerais c'est ENF citer peut-être
c'est é céser céser qui lui est
tantillaet Martin martiniquet
précisément qui était un ami intime de
Léopold Sédar sangor qui est et qui a
beaucoup écrit sur la négritude qui est
un des pères de la négritude le grand
poète de la langue française aussi
Abdrahman Waberi merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]